diese selbstgemachten chilinudeln dauern
unter 5 Minuten aber sie schmecken
unglaublich gut Timer starten und Nudeln
kochen Nudeln einfach ins Wasser
reingeben geb eine kleine Prise Salz
dazu und wir müssen uns gar keinen
Stress machen weil während die Nudeln
kochen kriegen wir den Rest easy fertig
hier habe ich eine Schüssel in die gebe
ich ein wenig Zucker getrocknete Chili
geriebenen Knoblauch und ingwa die
genauen mengangaben stehen wie immer in
der Beschreibung so jetzt benöen wir
heißes Öl das schütten wir einfach auf
unsere
Masse so brutzelt es jetzt vor sich hin
wir können ein bisschen durchrühren
vorsicht aber dabei und so entsteht eine
unfassbar geschmacksintensive Mischung
okay wenn ich fair bin das Nudelwasser
muss natürlich davor kochen und das Öl
muss auch schon heiß sein aber das hier
jetzt schütten wir die Nudeln ab und
geben Sie in unsere Schüssel jetzt etwas
von unserem Öl dazu das gibt den
Geschmack Leute Sojasoße und
Frühlingszwiebeln Stäbchen und
durchmischen und fertig sind unsere
selbstgemachten chilinudeln